hi Justin hi flora oh hi hi Laura I  can't believe it's six months since I'm  talking you're here yeah  is everything okay you just look so  different from your profile picture I  know it was actually about six months  ago you should update that since then  I've I've lost about fifty thousand or  fifty Jesus no partially because I quit  my job at Domino's so no more discounts  now at Domino's yeah  that's news it's all part of my  lifestyle change you know I had all  those cats yeah I had to adopt them out  you got rid of the cats yeah what about  the [ __ ] party we're gonna have I  thought you meant like a different kind  of party are you gonna have a [ __ ]  party without cats Laura oh no Laura not  that kind of a [ __ ] party jeez you seem  like a nice girl but I'm just not into  dating liars I fell in love with the  girl on your profile I wish you the best  of luck in your dating endeavors because  you're gonna need  you